es gibt gerade zwei sehr hohe
emotionspegel in diesem Land
[Musik]
wir wollen
verarschen zur Arbeit wir verlieren
unser Job dieser Tod bringt eine Alltag
das immer weiter so immer höher immer
schneller weiter das bringt uns gerade
in die Klimakatastrophe mit unserem
Protest richten wir uns ganz klar an die
Bundesregierung und sagen sie kann das
hier beenden aufgebrachte Bürgerinnen
und Bürger als Faust fand aufgebrachter
klimaaktivisten das ist die Lage fragt
man die Regierung ist das emotionslevel
hier allerdings bewusst runtergekühlt
kein Grund zur Aufregung heißt es da
alles im Griff der Bundeskanzler und
auch verschiedene Vertreter der
Bundesregierung haben sich in den
vergangenen Tagen und Wochen schon
häufiger dazu geäußert das ist die
Bundesregierung die so viel für den
Klimaschutz getan hat wie keine
Regierung vor ihr ist das so tut die
Regierung genug hat sie einen Plan
aktuell ist einfach kein
zusammenhängender Plan erkennbar wer hat
Recht Regierungssprecher oder letzte
Generation lasst uns mal zusammen
schauen wie dieser Mann der Kanzler für
Klimaschutz sein wollte wirklich tickt
wie die Klimabilanz seiner Regierung
aussieht und für welche Partei der
Protest besonders gefährlich werden
könnte außerdem soll es auch noch um das
eher schwierige Verhältnis der
klimaaktivisten zur Presse gehen auf
geht's zu einer neuen Folge
inside-politics
mein Name ist Andrea Maurer und ich bin
Korrespondentin im ZDF-Hauptstadtstudio
wie viele Kolleginnen und Kollegen war
ich in den letzten Tagen in Kontakt mit
der letzten Generation und finde das
Verhältnis der Aktivisten zur Presse
auch eher problematisch zum Beispiel
Pressekonferenz am 18 April in einer
Kirche in Berlin Kreuzberg hier sitze
ich und bin zwischenzeitlich ziemlich
verwundert einer der Aktivisten der
selbst mal Journalist war gibt uns fast
zehn Minuten Anleitung wie wir berichten
sollen was unsere Rolle ist ein No-Go
finde ich hört mal rein Sie die jetzt
hier sitzen sagen jetzt vielleicht aber
ich bin doch neutral ich bin Journalist
es gibt in der Klimakrise keine
neutralen Beobachter okay niemand
leugnet die Klimakrise aber wie dieser
Protest der sich selbst absolut setzt
einzuordnen ist das muss Gegenstand
einer freien Debatte sein das heißt ja
schließlich Journalismus und nicht
Aktivismus und nach dieser Klarstellung
schauen wir jetzt mal auf unserem selbst
ernannten klimakanzler und ob die
Performance seiner Regierung tatsächlich
so toll ist wie der Regierungssprecher
behauptet habt ihr ihn noch im Ohr das
ist die Bundesregierung die so viel für
den Klimaschutz getan hat wie keine
Regierung vor ihr
das Jahr in dem Urlaub Scholz Kanzler
wird ist das Jahr als die letzte
Generation erstmals in Erscheinung tritt
2021 das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat da
die Regierung damals ist es noch die
groko Ende des Jahres wird es dann die
Ampel zu mehr Klimaschutz verdonnert im
Bundestagswahlkampf verspricht Olaf
Scholz dann Kanzler für Klimaschutz zu
sein mit einem Hungerstreik erzwingen
die Aktivisten ein Gespräch mit ihm ich
habe mir das noch mal angeschaut das ist
eine Stunde die abläuft wie ein
Verkehrsunfall aufgebrachte Verzweiflung
der jungen Leute prallt auf fast
herablassende Ruhe des wahlgewinners das
ist so eine Art erster Stimmungstest für
zwei sehr unterschiedliche erregungs
Level ob sie dazu in der Lage sind uns
aus dieser Krise überhaupt rauszuführen
ich bin dazu in der Lage das ist mein
ganz konkretes ernsthaftes Vorhaben aber
wo ich mich mit ihnen unterscheide
möglicherweise ist das mit dem Hinweis
auf die ernsthaftes Problems noch kein
einziger konkreter Lösungsvorschlag
verbunden ist das ist ja die Sache von
Politik und demokratische Politik dass
ich sage
ganz lang danach gehen die Wege immer
weiter auseinander zwei Monate später
gibt es die ersten klimakleber einen
klimakanzler der sagt wo es lang geht
den gibt es nicht warum eigentlich im
Hintergrund sagen wir führende grüne das
Olaf Scholz das Thema Klima einfach
nicht besonders am Herzen liegt ja er
interessiere sich für die
technologischen Aspekte von erneuerbaren
Energien ja er interessiere sich für
planungsbeschleunigung und wie
Klimaschutz und Industrie zusammengehen
aber nein nein ein klimakanzler das sei
er nicht vor der Kamera sagt die
Fraktionsvorsitzende Katharina dröge das
dann so wer klimaschutzplakatiert hat
sollte Klimaschutz machen das wäre immer
meine Empfehlung also Corona Ukraine
Krieg Energiekrise überall geht woms
beim Klima offenbar nicht ein Scholz
Spruch aber der geht immer das wäre vom
Reden ins doing kommen
das also ist der neue Kanzler
klimaslogen allein schon aus macht
taktischen Gründen aber wird dieser
Kanzler beim Klima nicht vorangehen sagt
der Politik Professor Thorsten fast
nicht dieses Streit Thema zu eigen
machen würde ihn auch mit Streit in die
Öffentlichkeit bringen er müsste das mit
großem Nachdruck fast schon Brachialität
durchsetzen und das tut er zu weinen wir
haben es erlebt aber eigentlich nur ein
Ausnahmefällen also hält er sich eher
ein Stück weit zurück und lässt die
anderen das ausfechten die anderen das
sind seine Koalitionspartner die FDP und
die Grünen und bei keinem Thema liegen
die wohl so über Kreuz wie beim Thema
Klimaschutz
[Musik]
nichts scheint der FDP die bei
wärmewende und Verbrenner aus bremst
gerade mehr Freude zu bereiten als die
Grünen beim Thema Klimaschutz Platz zu
machen und die letzte Generation dazu
aufzufordern eine eigene Partei zu
gründen wer eine andere Politik will der
kann in die Politik gehen eine Partei
gründen und Mehrheiten für seine
Positionen erwerben ja logisch denn der
FDP würde diese Partei ja auch sicher
nicht gefährlich gefährlich würde sie
für die Grünen wie Thorsten Fass sagt
diese Aktivistin Aktivisten auf der
Straße sind sicherlich von den Grünen
stark enttäuscht weil das eigentlich
ihre natürlichen Partner in dieser
Koalition sind und sie sich sicherlich
wünschen würden dass die sich klarer zu
ihnen bekennen aber das ist ein Muster
was wir auch an anderer Stelle schon
gesehen haben dass gerade Menschen die
große Erwartungen Regierungen stellen
wenn das nicht passiert ist es durchaus
gefährlich für Parteien bis hin zur
Möglichkeit das neue Parteien entstehen
die Grünen jedenfalls mit denen ich
spreche die sind ziemlich fassungslos
wie sie als klimaschutzpartei in dieser
Koalition diese Art in die Defensive
kommen konnten Ende April
Koalitionsausschuss 30 Stunden der
Kanzler rückt in Sachen Klimaschutz nahe
ran an die FDP die muss ja dringend ihr
Profil in der Koalition schärfen mit
diesem Ergebnis die emissionsobergrenzen
werden aufgeweicht hier mal eine
erklärgrafik was das heißt bislang gilt
jeder Sektor wie etwa Energie
Landwirtschaft Verkehr Gebäude oder
Industrie hat verbindliche jährliche
Zielvorgaben weniger Treibhausgase
auszustoßen künftig soll ein Sektor auch
mehr freisetzen dürfen solange ein
anderer mehr einspart nur noch die
Gesamtrechnung soll entscheidend sein
das findet vor allem der FDP
Verkehrsminister Volker wir sind gut der
die sektorenziele regelmäßig reist der
Expertenrat für Klimafragen allerdings
den die Bundesregierung selbst
eingesetzt hat der findet das weniger
gut man kann sich das so vorstellen das
ist wie als wenn man am Anfang des
Jahres sagt ich möchte mehr Sport
treiben ich will fitter werden ich mache
dienstags gehe ich joggen und
donnerstags schwimmen und am Wochenende
mache ich noch einen Rundlauf um See und
jetzt ist es so dass die Regierung im
April feststellt naja vielleicht
sage ich einfach nur ich will fitter
werden bis Ende des Jahres und dann ist
die Frage ob das glaubwürdig ist und wie
weit man damit kommt Ambitionen
aufgegeben könnte man sagen
Glaubwürdigkeit in Gefahr übrigens auch
bei dem zentralen klimaversprechen der
Regierung Scholz einem Klimaschutz
Sofortprogramm als nächstes hört ihr
wieder massive Kritik diesmal aus der
Kanzlerpartei selbst wir hätten dringend
einen Sofortprogramm seit einem Jahr
gebraucht die Bundesregierung konnte
sich nicht verständigen und insofern
plädiere ich dafür auch dann Grad der
Verbindlichkeit gegenüber der
Bundesregierung von Seiten des Parlament
zu erhöhen die SPD-Fraktion fordert beim
Klimaschutz mehr Kontrolle der
SPD-geführten Regierung durch das
Parlament das muss man sich erstmal auf
der Zunge zergehen lassen wie war das
noch mit beste Klimapolitik aller Zeiten
mehr getan als jede Regierung zuvor so
und jetzt müssen wir noch mal schauen ob
der außer Parlament arischer Aufstand
der letzten Generation eigentlich
politisch irgendwas bringt
[Musik]
erste Antwort politisch vor allem
Abgrenzung hier mal ein kurzer Abriss
wie sich die einzelnen Parteien
positionieren CDU und CSU die Familien
gerne Klima RF Extremisten die SPD
findet dass das Ganze kein legitimes
protestmittel ist die Grünen sagen das
Ganze sei klimapolitisch kontraproduktiv
und rechtsstaatlich problematisch die
FDP findet es antidemokratisch totalitär
und autoritär die AFD spricht von einem
gezielten Rechtsbruch einzig die Linke
meint gefordert sei nicht das Strafrecht
sondern eigene politische Ideen und was
meint ihr laut einem aktuellen
Politbarometer lehnt eine große Mehrheit
von 82%
illegale Aktionen wie die Blockade von
Autobahnen ab sogar bei den Linken eine
Mehrheit von 61% und bei den Grünen
58%. so und wie seht ihr das er weiß die
letzte Generation die im klimaanliegen
einen Bärendienst über die Forderungen
jedenfalls wird politisch kaum
debattiert dafür aber sehr oft über
härtere Strafen schaut mal hier da sind
sich Oppositionsführer und SPD-Chef sehr
einig sind Gefängnisstrafen schickt
klimaaktivisten richtig
und besser höher als niedriger
es gibt ja die ersten Gefängnisstrafen
jetzt und ich habe der deutschen Justiz
da nicht zu widersprechen ich habe dazu
mal einen sehr interessantes Gespräch
mit der strafrechtsprofessorin Katrin
Höfler geführt ihr kommen solche
politikerreaktionen sehr bekannt vor es
ist halt oft erst mal billiger oder auch
für die Wähler interessanter wenn man
sagt wir brauchen ja harte Strafen auf
die klimaproteste anstatt zu den Leuten
zu sagen es geht einfach nicht mehr dass
ihr jeden Tag mit dem Auto zur Arbeit
fährt das kennen wir auch bei
Jugendkriminalität statt dass man auf
die sozialen Ursachen schaut sagt man
erstmal wir brauchen härtere Strafen für
Jugendliche so das heißt die politische
Handeln machen es sich mit der Forderung
nach härteren Strafen ziemlich leicht
und lenken natürlich auch ab von den
eigenen versäumen müssen klar ist aber
auch die Schnelligkeit und Radikalität
die die letzte Generation fordert die
könnte selbst eine noch ambitioniertere
Politik in einer Demokratie kaum leisten
hört mal was der protestforscher Dieter
ruft zu diesem Grund Widerspruch sagt
also es ist ein Dilemma dass man
einerseits sagt wir wollen natürlich die
Leute hinter uns bringen
aber zugleich vor der Herausforderung
steht dass man keine Zeit glaubt zu
haben das heißt es muss ein alles was
Klimaschutz angeht sehr sehr schnell
passieren aber Mehrheiten gewinnen das
ist ein langsamer Prozess und trotzdem
kann der Protest jetzt politisch auch
was bringen sagt ein anderer
protestforscher Janis Grimm es gibt neue
Studien aus Großbritannien zu extinction
Rebellion an der Vorläufer der letzten
Generation kann man ja so sagen die eben
ganz deutlich zeigen dass auch im
Gebieten wo extreme Bälle und
klimaaktivistin massiv an
sympathiepunkten verloren haben durch
ihre Aktion das allgemeine Bewusstsein
in der Bevölkerung für die Notwendigkeit
was gegen den Klimawandel zu tun eben
massiv zugenommen hat also zweite
Antwort was die letzte Generation bringt
sie speist das Anliegen Klimaschutz noch
mal radikal in die departeien auch wir
hier sprechen ja gerade darüber so und
hat er nun recht der Regierungssprecher
das ist die Bundesregierung wie so viel
für den Klimaschutz getan hat wie keine
Regierung vor ihr 49 Euro Ticket 20
milliar mehr für die Schiene Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren diese Regierung hat nicht
nichts getan das stimmt vielleicht muss
man es so sagen diese Bundesregierung
hat so viel für Klimaschutz getan wie
keine Regierung vor ihr einfach deshalb
weil die Regierung vor ihr noch weniger
getan haben wenn das allerdings der
Maßstab für die Ambitionen dieser
Regierung beim Klimaschutz ist ist das
erstens nicht genug und zweitens noch
lange kein Plan wie das einzuhalten ist
wozu sich diese Bundesregierung
verpflichtet hat Treibhausgas
Neutralität bis 2045 bereits bis 2030
sollen die Emissionen um 65% gegenüber
1990 sinken was meint ihr reicht das was
Kanzler und Regierung tun habt ihr
Verständnis für die Wut der Aktivisten
glaubt ihr wir kriegen das hin
diskutiert gerne mit und abonniert
unseren Kanal wir schauen hier
regelmäßig als korrespondentinnen und
Korrespondenten des ZDF Hauptstadtstudio
auf die aktuelle Politik und alles was
hinter den Kulissen passiert